شكرا عمار في تداعية يا زلزال تركيا
وسوريا اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ وقوع
زلزال بقوه خمس درجات على مقياس الاخضر
صباح اليوم في ناحيه جولباشي بمحافظه
اديمان جنوبيه البلاد كما وقع زلزال ثاني
في ملاطيه بقوه خمس درجات وسبعه اعشار
الدرجه على مقياس رختر ادى الانهيار مباني
عده ومقتل مواطن واصابه تسعه وستين اخرين
وكانت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد قتلى زلزال كهرمان مراشي
لاربعه واربعين الفا
وثلاثمائه واربعه وسبعين
هذه الصور مشاهدينا مباشره من ملاطيا التي
ضربها ايضا زيزان كما ذكرنا قبل قليل بقوه
خمس درجات
اذا مشاهدينا تستمر الضربات الزلازل في
تركيا عقب زلزلي كرمان مراش اخرهما اذا
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب ملاطي بقوه خمس
درجات و17 درجه على مقياس ريختر وادى الى
مقتل المواطن واصابه عدد من المواطنين
حوالي 69 اخرين ايضا كان هناك زلزال اخر
صباح اليوم في منطقه او ناحيه غولباتشي
بمحافظه اديمان جنوبيه البلاد وهي ايضا من
المحافظات التي تعرضت لزلزال كهرمان مرعش